One, two, three, four and five are the five digits given to us.
And we have been asked this.
How many five digit numbers can be formed using these five digits?
And we need to figure this out for two cases.
When repetition is not allowed,
and when repetition is allowed. If you haven't already,
I strongly recommend that you go through
our previous sessions based on forming numbers.
It will help you understand the session much better.
Okay, let's understand
what's been asked. In the first case,
we have been asked to find the number of ways
in which five digit numbers can be formed
when repetition is not allowed.
Okay, first things first, let's make five slots for the five digits.
Is there any condition given? No there isn't.
We have been asked for all five digit numbers
that can be formed using these five digits.
As there is no condition we can start from any end.
Let's start with the first slot.
In how many ways can the first slot be filled?
We can fill it with any one of the five digits, correct?
Yes, so there are five ways in which it can be filled.
Either a 1 or a 2 or a 3 or a 4 or a 5.
Now assume we have filled up the first slot with one of these digits.
With the first slot being filled, in how many ways can the second slot be filled?
As one digit is used here, four remain!
The second slot can be filled in four ways.
If the first slot is filled with a four,
then the second one can be filled with one, two, three or five.
If the first slot is filled with a two,
then the second one can be filled with a one, three, four or a five.
Now as two digits have been used in the first two slots.
the third one can be filled in three ways.
Similarly, the fourth one in two ways, and the last one is just one way.
Do we multiply these? Or do we add them?
Don't forget the basic rules of counting. "Or" is addition "AND" is multiplication.
As we are filling the first and the second and the third slots, and so on...
we will be multiplying these.
Five times four is 20.
20 times 3 is 60.
And 60 times 2 is 120.
There are 125 digit numbers that can be formed
using these five digits provided repetition is not allowed.
This is actually 5 factorial.
Many students memorise this.
Five distinct things can be arranged in five factorial ways.
Don't make that mistake.
Yes, you may use 5 factorial directly provided you understand
why we use the factorial.
Here, we saw it step by step.
why 5, why 4 and why we multiplied them?
Don't memorise the factorial formula.
Understand the logic behind it and then use it.
Now let's move on to the second part.
Five digit numbers when repetition of digits is allowed.
So we are allowed to form numbers like,
11111 or 52333 or 31443
where digits are repeated.
How do we begin? As always we go slot by slot.
The first slot can be filled with any one of the five digits.
It can be filled in five ways.
Now I want you to answer the next question.
Having filled the first slot with any one of the digits,
in how many ways can the second slot be filled?
As repetition is allowed,
it doesn't matter which digit we have filled in the first slot .
The second slot can be filled in five ways again.
Why was it 4 in the previous case?
Because we cannot reuse the digit that was used in the first slot.
In a similar way the third, fourth and the fifth slots
can also be filled in five ways each.
And we multiply these as we are filling the first,
and the second and the third slots and so on...
We get the answer as five raised to five ways.
We can form these many five digit numbers using these five digits,
provided repetition is allowed.
These problems are easy,
provided you understand the logic of repetition.
Let's look at one last question.
In how many can 6 seats be allocated to
six people?
Assume that the six people are a, b, c, d, e and f.
And imagine six chairs in a row
where these six people will be seated.
How will you solve this?
In how many ways can these six people be seated on these six chairs?
Pause the video and try solving it.
Think logically!
Isn't this the same as having six different digits and being asked
how many six digit numbers can be formed?
Of course without repetition.
Six different people are analogous
to six different digits.
Each number formed will be analogous
to each arrangement formed.
And it is obviously without repetition
as one person cannot be seated on two or more seats.
If one person is seated on chair 1,
he cannot be seated on Chair 2 as well, Right?
And what will the answer be?
Let's go back to the previous page.
Five digits in five slots when repetition is not allowed is this case.
5 Factorial.
Going back to the current problem the answer to it will be 6 factorial.
6 people can be arranged on 6 seats, in 6 factorial ways.
Here we have assumed that the seats are in a row.
The answer will be different if the seats are arranged in a circular fashion.
Don't worry about it for now!
We have covered circular arrangements in another session.